here wait are the worms all right cocoa
and cocoa what neighborhood over I grew
up and downtown LA likes caramel area
you grew up in Cedar Road I know that's
crazy there's a lot of people a lot of
times when I tell people that they don't
believe me they like living there yeah I
did actually did you see where the
hotels I sure did I stayed in the
frontier hotel oh the famous frontier
hotel I remember like it was yesterday
I literally stay like on the twelfth
floor one of my favorite topics any guy
in Skid Row is the frontier hotel oh
really crazy stories like that there's
some crazy stories about that place
don't tell me what you see oh I've seen
a lot of stuff in there like literally I
lived there for like over seven years
I've seen people jump off buildings I've
seen dead people inside of rooms
I've been walked inside the rooms and
people was having sex I don't see it all
living like I've seen you long hotel
I've ever heard
that's good it's a good hotel now but no
it's not it was yes it was an experience
that's the Rosewood yeah it was an
experience so tell me what your
childhood do with your parents I get I
had my mom and my dad but since my mom's
like drug dealers she was like in and
out of jail a lot you know so I was more
like just by my mom and my dad running
off but I was like really just like by
myself really - good luck your long life
yeah
but do any a crazy few something like
that he was kind of reluctant not crazy
abuse or anything like that but uh I got
molested a lot like when I was a kid
right by my brother's friends what
Adrian I was like 10
my 10 - Bobby like 14 is that a pretty
common occurrence and I don't know so
many times
Oh girls were probably like yeah for
pretty girls like you know even though I
was like younger like I used to be like
you know nice body and stuff like that
so I don't think it's pretty normal
because that's just not normal for you
don't want to touch a girl like under
age but I get I don't know I've heard a
lot yeah I would agree when you bomb
scare and okay so I had my first son at
15 so I'm probably like 13 14 like when
I was like on my own you know living I
was living in Tennessee the Huntington
hotel like on eight mean you know how
does a girl you know get to stay at her
hotel
you know what I used to break into the
rooms
hey what I was illegally living there I
used to break into the rooms and I was
in there and just go up in there and
sleep in the rooms like it wasn't
monitored no there was never any
security there was nothing like there
was nobody you know so I just just to
break into the world sleep in there and
then yeah are you working then they
prostituting
and you would bring guys there no I just
I just no one knew about it I was just
only working like on the streets you
know it was I couldn't tell my parents
they they wouldn't so 13 or girl working
the streets you pick up a guy and you
guys go where to hotels in the car or
something like that just different
things Alley 13 yo girl you how old do
you know 24 24 so 13 is there like a
high demand for this young girl well
yeah
what was it different like it's a
different what's your name now like I
don't know like versus like when I first
started it was high demand for everybody
like now I think like it's just like
watered down and people are just I don't
know what the world has come to honestly
I don't know but I don't know because
your I didn't I have two kids five to
eight year old son and I have a nine
month old daughter your your yeah well
my my sir my son is with his dad I just
raised my daughter here's the second
child's father died he got shot
gang you know
I'm really like talking about it
honestly you working with tensor without
cancer I work alone I work for myself
I've had pimps but I don't really what's
the upside in the downside of pimps well
I just feel like I'm just too grown to
be like asking people for stuff like so
that's like a downside for me like I
don't feel like I should have to like
wake up and ask somebody to feed me or
ask somebody to buy me something to wear
or whatever like you don't like that's a
downside to me because if I'm making the
money I should be able to do whatever I
want to do it like the upside of having
a pen I think a lot some of you feel
like it's not protection but it is like
you know like I don't know I just want
to really know up sighs that much I
don't know it's just for me of pimples
like having a blessing like just
somebody like have a good sex bit I
don't know different stuff typically
don't intimidate you into the
relationship today intimidated attempt
seem to be like use these intimidation
or with the girls
nah not for me normally these guys like
they sweet-talking me they don't yeah
they like seduced me I think yeah that's
how I get with the guys I get seduced
like they start trying to rub a booty
and I don't know yeah basically does
this work get to you sometimes you get
you down yeah a lot of times because I
just feel like I could do better like
even though the money is good I just
feel like where am I really gonna get
it's telling my [ __ ] on my life hey
we're nowhere this is just like a
repeated cycle with it like you just
wake up you did the same thing over and
over like we you know literally spending
money all the money that I make I spin
it and like you know or I'll give it to
somebody pamper I don't know whatever
you know I'm like yeah give me plants
and you'd like to see happen next five
years yeah eventually I want to leave
all these pimps alone and get myself
together save up like ten thousand
dollars I want to open this catering
truck like I've seen myself like on the
catering truck I've been looking into it
a lot like and you can typically make
like 10 thousand dollars off a catering
truck
in a month and the truck is only about
like $15,000 it's like I don't know but
I really I want to do that I actually
got somebody who's loving invested me
but I don't even want to take his money
because I feel like I'm not gonna do
what's right with it right now
you don't give me that $10,000 and I'm
gonna goddamn shot this breathing OH
do you have a lot of friends to do the
same thing yeah all my friends I don't
hang out with people that don't do what
I do of the girls that you went to high
school how many of them do this for
living um I know that many ones high
school yeah I did graduate high school
though but I graduated high school in
juvenile halls yeah what do you wish was
different about your childhood
redirected it I wish I didn't get
molested because like when I was getting
molested I thought it was okay you know
and I look he became addicted to sex no
I like I when the guys stop molesting me
like I I wanted sex like so bad like you
know like so like I wish like that that
would have never happened to me because
it like [ __ ] me up to the point where
like I thought it was okay to just go
around [ __ ] like having sex with
different men like just for the fun of
it like I don't know I was like living
in the night as he stopped I stopped he
stopped molesting me when I was like 13
I recently seen that guy - that's so
crazy and I've seen him when I said hi
to him and he was like he told me like
you got me jump
you got me betta he's like I hate you I
hope you die and I was like wait what he
was like you got me beat up like and I'm
like I didn't know what he was talking
about but he just like got on like you
know already worked out I figure out yes
Howard fig and Western
the Western is where West Western in
51st Street Western 54s you know Western
no yes you want alright cuz I love you
looking at you like oh he's a cop
now yeah I know you now no alright well
thank you so much for talking to me with
everything thinking I work with your
food truck thank you
you